LARRY, GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
>> YOU'VE GOT IT.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: MOSTLY FROM
DEMOCRATS, BUT ALSO FROM SOME
REPUBLICANS FOR NEW UNCONTROLLED
MEASURES.
DEMANDED OUTRIGHT GUN
COMPENSATION
CONFISCATION.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
WE DON'T AGREE ON MUCH.
I THINK YOU ARE A MAN OF GOOD
FAITH.
I LOVE HAVING YOU ON THE SHOW,
BUT WE DISAGREE ON MOST ISSUES.
YOU SAID SOMETHING REALLY
INTERESTING TO ME, AND I WANTED
YOU TO EXPLAIN IT MORE FULLY TO
OUR AUDIENCE.
>> THERE ARE SOME COMMON SENSE
MEASURES THAT I THINK MAKES
SENSE.
EVEN LIMITING THE CAPACITY OF A
MAGAZINE.
WE SAW IN CALIFORNIA WHERE A GUY
HAD A 75 ROUND DRUM CONNECTED TO
HIS WEAPON.
I'M AGAINST THAT.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE NEED THAT
I THINK WE NEED BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
GUN CONTROL IN THIS COUNTRY, IT
HAS BEEN TO KEEP GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF BLACK PEOPLE.
I WOULD POINT ANYONE TO ADAM
WINKLER'S WORK OUT OF UCLA.
IT WAS TO KEEP HANDS OUT OF BOTH
ENSLAVED AND FREE AFRICAN
PEOPLE.
AND THEN YOU GO TO ROGER, WHO
WROTE THE INFAMOUS DRED SCOTT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HE SAID
WAS THAT HE DIDN'T THINK THAT
BLACK PEOPLE HAD RIGHTS THAT
WHITE PEOPLE COULD RESPECT, IN
PART, BECAUSE HE THOUGHT THAT IF
YOU EXTENDED THOSE RIGHTS, THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE THE RIGHTS TO
CARRY AND OWN GUNS.
THE KU KLUX KLAN, THE TERRORIST
GROUP, CONSERVATIVE GROUP.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I'M SANE, THEY WERE DEMOCRATS.
>> AT THE SAME TIME, THEY WERE
ADVOCATES OF GUN CONTROL.
SO OBVIOUSLY, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE HISTORY OF THE ISSUE, I
THINK THAT AFRICAN-AMERICAN
PEOPLE SHOULD BE A LITTLE LEERY
ABOUT PEOPLE WANTING TO COME
AROUND AND TAKE THEIR GUNS.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK?
[LAUGHS]
YEAH.
I'M SORRY TO LAUGH, BUT YOU MAKE
A COMPELLING CASE, BECAUSE WHAT
YOU SAY IS TRUE.
WHEN YOU WANT TO OPPRESS
SOMEBODY, YOU DISARM THEM FIRST.
OF COURSE.
YOU'VE SEEN THAT IN TOTALLY
HOMOGENEOUS, WHERE RACE IS NOT A
FACTOR.
THE FIRST THING THE GOVERNMENT
DOES IS DISARM THE POPULATION
BEFORE DOING SOMETHING HORRIBLE.
OBVIOUSLY.
SO BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU SAID IS
SO CLEARLY TRUE, WHY IS IT SO
RARELY SET OUT LOUD?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE.
SOME OF OUR CIVIL RIGHTS HEROES
THAT ARE OFTEN TIMES NOT
ACKNOWLEDGED, WHETHER WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE DEACONS, OR WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT ROBERT OFF
WILLIAM.
I'M NOT SURE WHY PEOPLE DON'T
STATE THIS.
DR. KING, AT ONE POINT, WAS
CERTAINLY A GUN OWNER.
AT ONE POINT, THEY ACTUALLY
SAID, A JOURNALIST NEARLY SAT ON
TOP OF THE GUN IN HIS HOME AND
CALLED HIS HOME IN ARSENAL.
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
AT THE SAME TIME, THERE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE WORKED
AGAINST BLACK PEOPLE THAT ARE
PRO-GUN.
THEY ARE PRO-GUN-CONTROL WHEN IT
COMES TO BLACK PEOPLE, LIKE THE
NRA.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT HERE TO
SPEAK FOR THE NRA, BUT AS
SOMEONE WHO BELIEVES IN THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, I BELIEVE IT'S
UNIVERSAL PRINCIPLE THAT
APPLIES, IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING.
IT APPLIES TO ALL HUMAN BEINGS.
IT'S A GOD-GIVEN RIGHT.
THE RIGHT TO SELF-DEFENSE.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE OF GOODWILL
BELIEVE THAT.
HOW MUCH WILL YOU TAKE FOR
SAYING SOMETHING SO OBVIOUS
CUSTOMER >> I TAKE A EVERY TIME
I'M ON THIS SHOW FROM ONE SIDE
OR THE OTHER.
SO I THINK I'M PREPARED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.